[Musique]
bonsoir colas lier merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france un tiers
des israéliens qui ont déjà été
vaccinées mais nouveau confinement on
peut dire que la stratégie est bonne
mais que cela prend du temps
yannick martin oui je pense que la
plupart des israéliens autrement les
experts du gouvernement seraient des
corps jetés sur glace expliqué que la
campagne d'information pour nous devrait
atteindre ses objectifs d'ici à la fin
mars à ses est en bonne voie mais il
faudra plusieurs semaines avant tout non
pas les finalisations comme vous l'avez
dit un tiers des citoyens israéliens et
été actionnée c'est-à-dire avec 3
millions de personnes 3 millions de
personnes est un des cinq millions de
personnes ont reçu les deux doses avec
bien sûr et une période de 21 jours
entre les deux factions passivation
israël utilise des vaccins kaiser mais
également parfois le vaccin modern art
qui bloquent le pays est actuellement
confiné confinement a été prolongée
jusqu'à vendredi à 19h et le cabinet
ministériel se rassemblera mercredi afin
de décider si le confinement va encore
être en danger
le 1er mai sera une suite à distance qui
devrait être prolongée
donc on pense que la stratégie est bonne
même si les chiffres restent encore
inquiétant israël si j'ose dire
mais vraiment le paquet dans la lutte
contre ce virus sont deux armes le
confinement dont vous venez de parler et
le vaccin qu'on a payé plus cher en
israël qu'il faut combiner c'est
vraiment le prix à payer on est
convaincu de cela dans l'état hébreu
je pense que les gens en sont convaincus
on sait bien qu israël
à payer bien plus que d'autres pays pour
le vaccin un taux moyen de 47 dollars
dans personnes le l'israélien moyen ne
pas lui même le vaccin et assurances en
charge
mais cette différence et car les actions
c'est arriver le plus rapidement en
israël et ont été commentés en masse
c'est 350 milliards de dollars pour le
vaccin mais c'est une meilleure option
pour l'économie par rapport à un
compliment qui continue vous avez
également à mentionner l'économie en
général le taux de chômage est à 11% en
israël c'est un record sur les 15
dernières années l'économie souffre et
le dernier confinement dans le goutte
1,3 milliard de dollars par semaine
cependant il ya également les aéroports
qui ont été fermés ce qui signifie qu'il
n'ya plus de tourisme mais le tourisme
secteur majeur les israël se fondent
plutôt sur les technologies de pointe
qui permet beaucoup le télétravail et
donc il serait souffre moins que
d'autres pays
l'état hébreu qui a payé plus cher mais
qui a été aussi mieux servis par ce
qu'elle a accepté de fournir les données
un des personnes vaccinées
et ça c'est la bonne nouvelle si j'ose
dire du jour 1c que manifestement les
premières données sont plutôt optimistes
avec des bons résultats perceptibles
on a donné les chiffres tout à l'heure
vous nous confirmer cela il ya de vrais
bons résultats sur ces vacciner je suis
en terrain on considère effectivement
que le pays avance avance on a pu voir
que si le taux d'efficacité du vaccin
dépassé 90% comme on sait a bien dit
mais le taux de possibles le tonneau
qu'une une positivité n'a pas beaucoup
baissé et cela est dû en partie aux
ultra orthodoxes et aux personnes qui
ont voyagé au royaume uni ou en afrique
du sud et qui ont ramené avec eux ces
mutants et ses mutations du virus
c'est pour cela que les aéroports ont
été fermés et devraient rester fermés
pour encore deux semaines
je souhaite également mentionné les
ultra orthodoxes il y a eu de
funérailles
récemment et il ya eu d'importantes
réunions qui ont causé beaucoup de
colère une personne sur trois testeurs
positive à la coved sont des ultra
orthodoxes et benjamin netanyahu a été
plutôt lent a forcé le confinement dans
les communautés fortes doses car il a
besoin d'eux pour les élections qui
arrivent en mars une que bien sûr comme
dans tous les pays il y à des politiques
derrière tout cela mais en tout cas le
pignon sur le terrain c'est que les
ultra orthodoxes le jouent pas leur rôle
ne sont pas aussi prudents qu'ils ne
devraient l'être et il souhaite que le
gouvernement soit plus stricte envers
les communautés religieuses ultra
orthodoxes qui ne respectent pas le
confinement ne porte pas le masque ne
respectent pas les gestes barrière
justement voilà le parlement israélien
qui s'est prononcé en faveur d'une
augmentation des amendes contre les
contrevenants aux restrictions
sanitaires c'est la bonne méthode y
compris chez ses ultra orthodoxes qui on
l'aura compris respectivement
la règle c'est la bonne décision les
amendes ont doublé la situation est
effectivement que certains ignorent les
règles
les aéroports sont fermés et ça fait 1
disent que c'est une bonne chose
d'autres disent que ce n'est pas
nécessaire et c'est trop tardif mais
voici un exemple de gens qui ignorent
les règles ils reviennent en
elle et ne s'isole pas pendant deux
semaines à domicile par exemple ils
sortent de chez eux en laissant leurs
téléphones chez eux donc les autorités
pensent qu'ils sont à domicile alors
qu'ils se déplacent dans le pays
c'est un secret de polichinelle les
autorités savent que certaines personnes
ne respectent pas ces règles d'isolement
à domicile et j'ai également mentionner
ces variants venus du royaume uni où
l'afrique du sud ou du brésil la
fermeture des aéroports c'est une façon
pour traiter le problème
augmenter les amendes c'est un autre
fait une autre solution mais la
communauté ultra orthodoxe est
extrêmement pauvre donc on lève des
amendes encore plus forte contre une
population qu'ils pouvaient à peine se
les permettre auparavant donc est-ce que
cela va vraiment modifier les
comportements des ultra orthodoxes
on ne sait pas ce qu'il faudrait c'est
que c'est que les rabbins
ultra-orthodoxes tragique indique thaler
communauté qu'il faut respecter le
confinement et suivre les règles et la
plupart des rabbins ont refusé de faire
cela disant que les grands
rassemblements font partie de leur
culture et que les les membres de cette
communauté n'ont pas besoin de respecter
les confinement strict merci paul à
slayer journalistes pour arte
internationale d'avoir été en vue de
l'extérieur ce soir